welcome to the man of Recaps this is Ted
lasso season three Ted lasso is back the
American football coach coaching
football in England which of course over
there is the totally different sport
Americans know as soccer in season two
with the power of Ted's positive
attitude he led AFC Richmond out of
relegation back the Premier League but
of course they're now the worst team in
the Premier League so they're mostly
expected to lose the team's former
Hitman turned Mastermind tactician
Nathan Shelley Nate the great now known
as the wonder kid he left on bad terms
last season the fame got into his head
he's become kind of a dick now he's
coaching their rival team owned by
Rebecca's ex-husband Rupert who's become
Nate's new douchebag Mentor the show's
main couple Roy Kent and Keely have
broken up this season for no good reason
Roy's self-sabotaging healy's busy being
the boss of her own new PR firm where
she has to deal with her Downer finance
officer Barbara when Keeley runs into
one of her old model friends she gives
her a job but turns out she's terrible
and Keely has to fire her and she does
not take it well our favorite former
reporter Trent Crim of the independent
is writing a book on Richmond this
season so he hangs around more joins the
main crew now there's a big shake up in
the football World when Legendary player
Zava wants to come to England rebecc
Welton wants to recruit him for Richmond
but it looks like Rupert got to him
first so Rebecca Corners him in the
bathroom like hey you can play for a
good team before she'll win if you want
to prove you're the best come play for a
bad team and see if you can win anyway
and it works zava's joining Richmond
he's a funny character but he really is
that good Richmond goes on a win streak
but not all players are happy with Zava
taking the spotlight their former best
player Jamie tart thinks he could be
that good too so his old rival
tournament or Roy Kent's like alright
kid I'll train ya starts waking him up
early to get in extra workouts most of
the big players get their own Side
Stories like Sam obasania opens a
Nigerian restaurant but one day he
stands up for justice on social media
and of course a lot of trolls don't like
that and they all trash the restaurant
but then it's heartwarming as the whole
team pitches in to fix it one player
Colin turns out he's gay and he's afraid
if he tells his teammates they won't
accept him but Trent Crim turns out his
gay too gives him some advice and when
he does come after the team it's
heartwarming as of course they accept
him the team's goalie the Canadian Zorro
keeps correcting everyone it's
pronounced zero Bowen Zava tells him he
can be whoever he wants he changes his
name to Van Damme later his teammates
Danny Rojas takes the Canada Mexico game
too seriously and kicks the ball right
in his face after that he has to wear a
protective mask but Danny feels bad and
gets him a cool black mask just like the
one famously worn by the swashbuckler
Zorro and so Zorro starts going by Zorro
and has reached his final form team
owner Rebecca Welton went to see a
psychic who predicted some weird stuff
but it starts happening like the green
matchbook she also predicts Rebecca will
have a family and Rebecca always wanted
kids so she goes to a fertility clinic
but it turns out no she's too old but
now it's football time as the team faces
their biggest rival led by their old
friend Nate and the Wonder kid is the
master of tactics knows how to nullify
the Zava Advantage so at halftime they
show the security footage of Nate
ripping up their belief sign which gets
him riled up but it rattles him up a bit
too much and they end up blowing the
game after this Richmond goes on a
losing streak and Zava is not having fun
anymore he decides to retire and pursue
his real passion of his avocado farm so
coach lasso brings down the believe sign
and tears it up even more look guys this
was just a sign the real belief is
inside you all along but belief on its
own isn't enough you also need a
strategy and all season long the team's
been struggling to find a good formation
in Amsterdam they're looking for
inspiration so coachbeard boots him up
some mushroom tea to open their minds
and Ted's baby down to try some
hallucinogens but he really still
doesn't like like tea instead he goes to
the American themed restaurant where
they're playing an old basketball game
instead has a barbecue sauce induced
Epiphany to try basketball free flow
informations in soccer of course this
isn't a new idea it was a popular
technique in the 70s called total
football and so the team ties their
Willies together to learn how to move
around in sync and the strategy finally
comes together when Jamie Tarr realizes
as the best player he shouldn't be in
the front he should be in the middle and
now Total Football is really cooking and
Richmond's on another win streak the
biggest game for Jamie tart is that his
former team Man City where last season
he had a really bad run-in with his
father but coach lasso gives him a pep
talk Jamie maybe you gotta forgive your
dad not for him but for yourself and it
works Jamie Tarts become a superstar and
a real good person compared to the jerk
he started as in season one now let's
check in on romance arcs once a season
Ted lasso hooks up with Rebecca's friend
sassy this time he's like hey should we
date but she's not interested she's like
yo we're both a mess and yeah Ted is
still processing his ex-marriage one day
he calls home and finds out his wife is
seeing someone seriously but not just
anyone Dr Jacob their marriage counselor
which is you know a little unethical
this message head up a bit but
eventually he accepts that they're happy
and he focuses on his relationship with
his son Keeley meets her company's
investor Jack who turns out is a young
woman like herself and they get along
great in fact real great these two start
dating and it's a fantastic start to a
new relationship but there's a big leak
of celebrity nude photos and keeley's
one of them a video she sent an
ex-boyfriend Jack has her PR people
right Keely an apology but keeley's like
wait why should I apologize and they
can't see eye to eye on this so they
break up and Jack unfortunately defunds
keeley's company he luckily keely's
other friend Rebecca is also rich and
invests instead Rebecca in Amsterdam
made the classic tourist mistake of
walking on the bike lane and got knocked
off the bridge luckily there's a hot
Dutchman nearby to take her onto his
houseboat and dry her clothes and these
two have a magical evening together
where it's like well probably never see
you again Nathan Shelley now kind of
famous is able to date supermodels but
supermodels aren't really into the real
nerdy nape the girl Nate really likes
his Jade the hostess at his favorite
Greek restaurant and she is into the
real nerdy Nate eventually he gets the
courage to ask her out and these two
become a real cute couple but his new
Mentor Rupert doesn't approve he's like
yo Nate all cool dudes cheat on their
girlfriends and Nate realizes this isn't
who he wants to be so 8 quits the team
and starts waiting tables but pretty
soon he gets visit from coach beard who
gives long story about how Ted lasso
forgave him once and so now he's willing
to forgive Nate and Nate gives Ted his
own big apology and so the team forgives
him with only mild punishment and so as
we reach the end of the season Rebecca
normally has a big truth bomb about how
she was sabotaging the team to get back
at her ex but this season now
everything's good she's happy just being
the better person but it's Ted lasso
himself who has some bad news he's
leaving after the season going home to
spend more time with his son and so on
Ted's last day of practice the team does
an adorable Goodbye song from The Sound
of Music and then another heartwarming
surprise they all kept a piece of the
belief poster and put it back together
in the final game Richmond's been doing
so well they've got a chance to finish
first in the league it comes down to the
final play where they go for one of
neeks the Great's old strategies use
Jamie tart as a distraction to pass to
an open player and all Richmond wins yes
they've done it Underdog Story from
bottom of the league to number one well
actually they finished second in the
league because of how English football
works but it's still triumphant a
beautiful moment and the team gathers
around coach lasso as he does the dance
the same one that made him famous in
season one so the shows come full circle
but now Ted lasso's job here is done
like Mary Poppins he flies off after
helping everyone else become a better
person his best friend coach beard
though is not coming with remember he's
fallen in love with his girlfriend here
Jane Unfortunately they already sealed
the airplane doors but coachbeard fakes
a medical emergency to get out of there
and has his own weird wedding then
Rebecca has a run-in with a random
little girl who turns out is the
daughter of hot Dutch pilot guy from her
magical night together and it looks like
Rebecca will have a happy family Roy
Kent has become a much better man and
apologizes to Keeley but Jamie tart has
also become a much better man and he and
Keely start talking too and the former
Rivals Rory and Jaime have become best
friends themselves but they do beat each
other up over who gets to be with Keely
of course Keeley leaves them both
hanging so Roy Kent becomes the new head
coach and the Richmond dream team is
still here just without Ted but he's
always in their hearts indeed Trent Crim
called his book The lasso way but Ted
was like yo it wasn't about me so he
renames it just the Richmond way and so
Ted lassos back in America where he can
be a good father to his son in fact he
starts coaching his little league soccer
team and that's where Ted lasso comes to
an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]